[Music]
the New York City Subway is the
circulatory system for the global
capital of finance and media and today
this one hundred and fourteen year old
engineering marvel is coming apart Stahl
train signal breakdowns and constant
line closures are complicating the lives
of New Yorkers who ride the trains more
than five and a half million times a day
the MTA the public agency that runs the
subways is woefully mismanaged fiscally
irresponsible and politically captured
thanks to the cloud of the transit
workers Union subway workers on average
make a hundred and fifty-five thousand
dollars in total annual compensation or
more than twice as much as the
passengers they serve the political
response to this crisis has been mainly
to devise new ways to collect more money
for this troubled operation such as a
new millionaire's tax or by imposing
additional tolls and surcharges on cars
but a major lesson from the first
hundred and fourteen years of subway
history is that giving the MTA more
money from outside sources is like
bringing an alcoholic to an open bar the
path to real reform and accountability
is to make the subway live off its
customers once and for all subway riders
should bear almost the full cost of the
ride with the exception of low-income
folks where there's going to be some
subsidy baruch Feigenbaum is the
assistant director of transportation
policy at The Reason Foundation but fair
in New York City is couple bucks and
change what would it be if it was more
fully accounted so during rush hours it
would probably be at least five dollars
one way and probably up to eight or
maybe even ten based on how far the
person is traveling we charge what it
takes to cover the cost and then for
folks who need the service they would
get a voucher or some sort of other
discount so they can use it we're not
trying to subsidize upper middle class
folks here one of the arguments against
that is it's going to decrease economic
overall because there is a positive
externality to subsidize some people to
come into Manhattan from the borough's I
really don't think eight or ten dollars
even is that much when you consider some
of the other challenges in New York and
people still live there at the center of
everything does not have to be Manhattan
is that the limit of transit policy that
people ride you pay the full cost that
is the most efficient system it's also
the best system for the rider because if
the rider is the one paying the cost
then the transit agency is serving the
rider if Albany is bailing out the
transit system it's going to be whatever
Albany wants
lately whatever Albany wants has
included budget items big and small that
don't have any impact on service and
reliability and this is a theme that
extends all the way back to the system's
early days the subways troubles are
deeply rooted in the decline of the fare
as its primary revenue source
[Music]
here's what happens every day in the
crowded old subway when the subway
opened in 1904 was five cents a ride
which was more than enough to finance
operations but when inflation eroded the
value of a nickel the city refused to
permit fare increases by 1920 500 other
US cities had raised fares on their
transit systems meanwhile New York
City's populous Mayor John Highland
campaigned on the preservation of the
nickel fare calling it as sacred and
binding as any contracts ever drawn in
the history of financial transactions
the world over the fair did eventually
go up but not enough to keep pace with
inflation and the subways revenue
shortages became an endemic problem
decades later the city and state
discovered a new way to plug up the
shortfall forcing drivers to pay for
transit in 1968 Governor Nelson
Rockefeller orchestrated a backroom deal
to reallocate revenues from nine major
bridges and tunnels to transit last year
alone drivers paid 1 point 1 billion
dollars in tolls that were diverted to
subways and buses the state created more
hidden funding streams in the years that
followed and taxes and subsidies now
comprise a larger share of the MTA's
revenue than fares these include a
special sales corporate and payroll tax
and fees on real estate transfers car
rentals drivers license renewals and
vehicle registrations and the state just
imposed a brand new surcharge on taxis
and ride shares coming into Manhattan
with the money going to the MTA these
subsidies violate a central tenet of
good transportation policy which is to
make each mode of travel self-sustaining
if fair subsidies were to come to an end
could the subway survive on its
customers alone it could in 1904 when
the system open and it could in 1982
when the MTA studied the issue and
journalist Peter Samuel wrote about it
in reason the key is getting writers
directly invested in slashing wasteful
spending and reining in wildly inflated
salaries by making them feel the horror
not just of signal malfunctions train
rerouting in line closures but that
they've paid top dollar for the
privilege of such dreadful service
convenient and we thank you for your
patience